all right we are ready for the next talk
in the session
sh so I'm and then this is
Jo my advisor who also in the audience
um oh okay so today I'm going to talk
about uh our new Fox result which is the
complexity of dynamic Le squares
regression um but before I move on to
the dynamic problem let's first remind
us of the canical Le s regression so
this is also called L2 regression uh and
then D covered the harder LP regression
in her previous talk but today we're
only going to focus on the L2 Norm so in
this problem our goal is to find the
vector X that minimize the L2 Norm of ax
minus B and we should think of a as a
very thin and Tall Matrix and it has all
the datas so the least Square regression
problem has many applications and it's
the simplest way to model some data so
basically if you have a lot of data
points this will give us a linear um
model that fits the
data okay and the L2 normally scratch
regression is very simple because we
have an exact solution to this problem
so the exact solution is given by this
normal equation where it's computed by
some inverse time a transpose time B so
you can compute this exact solution um
by using fast Matrix modifications if
you compute this from scratch it would
take n * D to the Omega minus one time
where Omega is the fast matrix
modifcation it's about 2.37 right now
and the bottom neck to compute this is
to compute this matrix multiplication
inside the
inverse okay but often this is due too
slow for many more than data analysis
applications and often in real life
we're happy to just get an absolon
approximate solution so here we will
define an absolon approximate solution
to be a vector X such as the norm of ax
minus B it at most 1 plus Epsilon of the
optimal
value and if we're we are happy with
Epsilon approximation then we can use
the sketch and solve Paradigm and the
best uh running time right now is nearly
linear in the input size so right now
it's basically nza time log one Epsilon
not that the dependence on Epsilon is
also
logarithmic okay and now in this paper
we consider a dynamic version of the Le
squares regression problem so in the
dynamic version our goal is to maintain
an absolum approximately Le Square
regression solution where we allow
insertions or deletions of the rows and
the labels to our data Matrix
okay and our goal now is that whenever
we receive a new update so it can be an
addition of a new row or a deletion of a
row we wanted to minimize the advertised
update time and uh so now we think of
there are in total n iterations and we
should think of n as being much larger
than D so think of n as some big
polinomial of D and this models uh some
Dynamic data applications uh for example
in continue ml which is more complicated
than this this is the simplest model
where we already trained some model
based on our existing datas but we're
still actively collecting new data and
we wanted to incorporate the new data
into our model without retraining our
model from scratch ination which could
be too
expensive okay and then there are some
important settings that we consider in
this paper and I should Define them
right now the first is incremental
versus fully Dynamic so we call uh a
problem CA the updates are incremental
if we only receive new roles so we only
collect new data but we never throw away
our existing data and this the harder
update would be a fully Dynamic update
where we are receiving both insertions
and delions of the
roles okay and the second difference is
between oblivious updates and adaptive
updates so for oblivious updates we can
think of it as in the beginning even
though we don't know what the updates
are but they are fixed and they don't
depend on what our algorithm do but
adaptive updates we allow some adversary
to choose the next update based on the
solution that's generated by previous
outputs so these two updates are the
same for the algorithm if the algorithm
is deterministic but if the algorithm is
randomized then the Adaptive updates can
be much harder because then your update
in the next run could depend on the
randomness that you use in your
algorithm so it could break break some
independent that we might use in the
analysis okay uh and before I go to our
result let's first say what are some
existing algorithms for this problem
well this problem has a long history so
it was first it was already studied in
the 60s by the control people so by the
common filters so if we wanted to just
maintain the exact solution of this
problem we don't need to compute the
inverse from scratch in every iteration
as double take like into the Omega ter
to the Omega ter um can just use
Woodburry identity for Matrix inverse
and would give a time per update of D
Squared and this is a deterministic
algorithm and it's exact so it works for
the hardest fully Dynamic and adaptive
updates but if we're happy with just
getting an absolute approximate solution
then there are more recent results that
use online Ro sampling where they don't
keep all the big uh data Matrix they
just sample much fewer number of r roles
so in this paper by kohen musco and
palki where they show that they can
maintain an Absol approximate Solution
by sampling D Times log Kapa over
Epsilon squared number of rows where
Kapa is some uh condition number of the
data
Matrix and I should say uh and their
algorithm only works for incremental and
oblivious
updates and I should say that because
they their paper didn't really care
about the Le Square regression problem
they cared more about maintaining a
spectral approxim uh spectral
approximation of the inverse Matrix so
if we just apply their algorithm
directly it will still take the square
time but this time is to compute the
sampling probability I'll say more later
when I go to the details uh and the more
recently there's a new paper by bman at
all where they show how to generalize
this online Ro sampling framework under
adaptive and still incremental updates
but here they will lose a linear
dependence in Kapa so here they will
need to sample more number of rows they
will need to sample D squ time Kapa Kapa
over Epsilon squ number of rows and
because they still compute the sampling
probability still takes D squ time so
the question we ask in our paper is can
we achieve better time can we achieve of
order D time per update and can we
achieve nearly linear time uh during all
iterations and we answer this question
affirmatively so our upper bound shows
that there is a data structure that can
maintain an absolum approximate Le
Square regression solution under
oblivious incremental updates with a
total running time of ND plus d cubed
times some polom of L Epsilon we can
also make this algorithm work against
adaptive but still incremental updates
um and we still get the first and D term
but we will lose something in the second
term it will become uh D to the 5ifth
instead of D Cub okay and since we we
consider the situation where n is much
larger than d uh and then if we also
assume that Epsilon is some small
constant then this will give our desired
amortized cost per iteration that's of
order D so this is improves from the
previous D Squared uh cost per iteration
and I also wanted to add even though I
write ND here for this talk but it's
actually NZ of a n so it's nearly linear
time during all iterations and that U
matches what we get in the static
case and I should also I also want to
mention that I don't write any condition
number in this uh in these upper bounds
because we improve the number of sample
rows for this Pur paper from a linear
dependence in the condition number where
the condition number might be polinomial
we can prove this to a log dependence so
I'm just hiding the log inside this UD
notation
here okay so now if we look at this
upper band again um there are two place
the two places that don't seem super
tight there seems to be some still some
room of improvement first one is that we
will have a polom dependence on one
number Epsilon but if you remember a few
slides ago I showed that the best
algorithm for the static case only have
a log dependence on one or Epsilon so is
it possibil to improve this and the
second place that doesn't seem super
tight is both of these two algorithms
only for work for incremental updates
they don't even though we can work
against adaptive updates but it's still
when they're only incremental what
happens if the updates are fully Dynamic
we still get of order the update time
but unfortunately we have some lower
round results that show that the both of
these two questions are not
possible so our our result our lower
bounds are all conditional lower bounds
based on the omv conjecture that I will
say in more details when I go to the
later sections but under the omv
conjecture we show that if we want a
data stru to maintain a very high
accuracy the square regression a one
over poly and approximate the square
regression even under the easiest
oblivious and incremental updates then
this would take D squar time so it means
we cannot possibly get some running time
that looks like d Times log one over
Epsilon because that would break this
lower round so this basically means we
cannot improve that PO dependence onon
to some
dependence and our second lowerbound
result shows that if we want the
algorithm to support fully Dynamic and
adaptive fully Dynamic updates then even
if we just wanted to maintain some
constant approximation this is already
too hard this would take D Squared time
per iteration so it means we cannot
generalize our upper bound to work for
fully Dynamic updates so basically this
is uh a negative result to both of the
previous two questions okay so next I
will move on to more details of all
these results um and my talk today will
be have three parts the first part is
the upper bound but under oblivious
incremental updates and in the second
part I will say how we let the algorithm
work for adaptive updates and in the
third part I will go into the lower
rounds so are there any questions um for
the
results yes so oblivia fully Dynamic
update is possible yes uh we don't know
whether there's an algorithm or there's
a lower one it's still
open
okay actually s fast yes's what's the
best known for adaptive play Dynamic
updates is there an obvious t squ
solution or it's like yes there's the
exact solution where you just update the
normal equation by using would vary that
just takes d square time and it's exact
it's deterministic so it works for any
update yeah
yeah okay sorry why doesn't that have an
end oh this is amortized cost per
iteration s
peration okay so let's first go to the
upper bound uh for incremental and
oblivious
setting so let me first re uh Define
some notations that I will use
throughout this talk so now we're
considering incremental settings we
assume that in the ice iteration we're
given a new row which is the oted by Ai
and the new label which is just a number
denoted by Beta I and our goal is to
solve for um this Square regression
problem so we will use Capital AI to
denote our data Matrix up to the ice
iteration so we have the current I rows
and we'll use bi to denote our labels up
to the I
iteration okay and I first wanted to
cover the exact solution because our
algorithm will also use this in some way
so the exact solution just compute the
normal equation exactly in each
Direction and the hardest B NE to update
this noral equation is to update the
inverse if we do it naively would take D
to the Omega time to compute the inverse
but luckily we notice that from the
inverse that we already have in the
previous itation this is just a rank one
update so we can use the rootberry
identity for Matrix inverse that
basically says it's a I is to just
compute a matrix Vector product in order
to update this inverse and this takes d
s time so this is also the algorithm
that would work for any update okay and
this is if we wanted to do a exact
solution but we are actually happy to
just maintain an absolum approximate
solution so what are some techniques
that are used in the static case for
just absolute approximate
Solutions well the stand standard
technique is called Subspace embedding
and then a lot of this is covered in the
survey by David bu so for Subspace
embedding if we are given a very tall
Matrix a we can have a matrix as to
compress this larger Matrix a into a
much smaller Matrix S A and we say that
s is a subop space embedding a one plus
Epsilon Subspace embedding for the
Matrix a if this sa Matrix preserves the
norm
of a for any X so if the norm of S A
Time X is a 1 plus absolute
approximation of the norm of a x for all
X then we say this is a Subspace
embedding and if we have a Subspace
embedding for the Matrix or Matrix a and
the labels B then we can directly use
that to get an absolute approximate
solution for the least Square regression
problem what do we do is we just solve
um this smaller problem this compressed
problem from the Subspace embedding and
then this problem is directly a absolute
approximate solution for the original
Square regression
problem okay so what we wanted to do
when we wanted to we wanted to make this
all Dynamic we wanted to make this work
for so we wanted to dynamically maintain
some Subspace inue of our Matrix a and
there are many different techniques that
can achieve sub space imaing one um very
widely used technique sketching
techniques where add some random Matrix
but the sketching techniques is a little
hard to dynamize because uh this Matrix
can be dense and it can depend on all
rows of a so what we use is we use this
sampling technique that just samples
some rows of a and it throws away the
other rows that we don't keep and this
technique is much easier to
diiz okay so next let me go into what is
the lar score sampling so for a fixed
Matrix a so I'm in this slide I'm going
to Define this lar sampling for a fixed
Matrix a and on the next slide I will
say how to make it
Dynamic so for a fixed Matrix a and
let's call its ISO AI we can define a
leverage score for its ice row by this
equation so AI transpose times this
inverse time AI That's illustration here
and it's also it's the diagonal entries
of the projection Matrix that's defined
by
a and intuitively what is a lever score
intuitively a lever score measures how
important the I row is for the row space
of a so if a leverage score of one row
is one this means this row is very
important if we remove this row then
will decrease the rank of a by
one and if all the rows are the same
then they will all have the same uh
importance oh by the way during this
talk I'm always going to assume that um
this Matrix have four column rank so
it's rank is D so when the rowes are all
the same then they all have the same lar
score and will be D over and the Lar
scores have two main properties one is
that all the leverage scores are between
zero and one and the second is that the
summation of them will become the rank
so basically this a it's a way to
measure how important the row is and
then all of them together it equals to
the
rank okay and what is the lar score
sampling so it basically says if we
sample the I row with a probability
that's proportional to its leverage
score and this over abson squared uh if
we sample a row with this probability
and then we keep this row with up to
some scaling and then we throw a row
away we don't sample it then the sample
Matrix sampling Matrix D will give us an
absolon Subspace embedding for
a okay and because we are sampling with
probability that's proportional to the
lever score and then we know the sum of
the leverage score is C so expectation
will will sample um roughly D over Epson
square number of
rows yeah there's log in somewhere sorry
I should WR o here sorry yeah yeah so
like with high probabilties there should
be a log one Delta dependence if we want
probility okay uh and then this recent
paper by koham musco and they
showed how to make this leverage score
sampling work in the online setting so
we can then Define the online online
leverage scores uh which is defined as
the
this still the i r but the Matrix in the
middle is not the whole matrix it's the
Matrix that we get up to the I minus
one's iteration so it's our current
Matrix and this online lar scor is
always overestimates of the true
leverage scores why because according to
the Matrix order Matrix partial order
the smaller Matrix is always smaller
than the the the whole Matrix so these
online lever scores are always
overestimated and this is also one of
the reason from the upper bound side why
incremental setting is much easier than
the fully Dynamic setting because in the
incremental setting we are always
Computing The Leverage for according to
some smaller Matrix so they are always
uh overestimates but if you also have
some deletion of the rows then the
previous L scores that you computed
could be an underestimate and it's a
little harder to deal with and because
it's
overestimates um we can directly sample
with a higher probab we can still get
the Subspace in beding uh guarantee all
same as
before okay but the problem with the
overestimate is that now the number of
sample rows is still the summation of
all the sampling probability so it's
still the summation of all these online
lever scores but they are over up
estimates so we'll need you need some
upper bound on the
thms and this was shown by this previous
paper where they show that we will just
lose some log decup half factor in order
to bound the sum of all the online
average scores okay and the proof is
actually pretty simple that I can cover
just in this space they just use this um
Matrix fact which says that the log that
of some Matrix M with a rank one change
is larger than the log that of the
Matrix M plus this a transpose M inverse
a so if we apply this to the rows if we
take a to be the row and then take this
m inverse to be this inverse Matrix then
this value is exactly the online
leverage source and then what they Prov
that use this L log that function as a
potential function and then you just
compute the difference from the ins
iteration up to the zero iteration and
we'll get the summation of all the
online leverage scores so the summation
of all the online leverage scores
smaller than the log that of your final
Matrix minus the log that of your
initial Matrix and that's exactly bonded
by um Capa to the by by dapa like um so
that's why we get this log deapa Factor
here okay so similar as before in
expectation we will sample the summation
of Pi number of rows and now this is D *
log over Epsilon squ number of rows I'm
hiding some further log and in the
loation okay so now after we described
this we're ready to describe the
algorithm for previous updates so in the
algorithm we will always maintain a sub
subsample Matrix where the D is the
sampling Matrix according to the L
online leverage scores and ination when
the new Ro arrives will first compute
its online leverage score U by using
approximately uh by using the subsample
Matrix that we already
maintained and then we will flip a CO
with probability that's proportional to
this leverage score and if we sub get
one from the coin then we will add uh a
scaled version of the row as a new row
to our subsample Matrix and we will
update the inverse and the solution and
if it's zero then we just throw away
this zow and then we don't do any update
and then we still output the same
solution okay so now next let's balce
the running time of this algorithm so
there are two steps that are that we
need to care about the first step is to
compute the sampling probability this
second step is when we're performing the
updates so let's first B this second
time um so when we're doing the update
we can just use what we do for the exact
solution we just update it by using this
uh wear identity for Matrix inverse and
this will take d square time to do this
update and as we showed on this previous
Slide the total number of updates is
founded by the sum of the online
leverage scores and it's bounded by D *
log Capa or EPS squ so we just multiply
these two together and this gives us the
total time for this update uh operation
and this is actually a smaller term this
is the second D Cube term in our final
running time and when n is much larger
than D this is a very small term this is
D to the
L okay so next let's talk about um the
time for computing The Leverage scores
so if we comput it directly that's like
if you don't do any tricks that's what
in the previous papers this would take d
square time why because the Matrix
already have size d by D and if you just
wanted to multiply The Matrix with the
vector will take d square time uh but we
can use this Johnson lindus TR Lama to
accelerate this computation the Johnson
lindus TR LMA says that there exists
some JL Matrix J that is very very flat
so it only have log a number of rows and
uh this Matrix J can preserve the L2
Norm of a number of fixed vectors
and we we notice that we can write the
online leverage score as some L2 Norm so
what we do is that we let the algorithm
also maintain a sketched version a JL
sketched version of The Matrix so now
that instead of computing a uh this
product which is like a n byn Matrix
times sorry a d byd Matrix time a size d
Vector we compute something that's much
cheaper so we just compute this product
this is the Matrix that we already
maintain and it only have size log and
times D and then we multiply that by a
size d VOR so this time this only takes
uh D Times log in time actually it only
takes n z of AI time but I'm writing D
here just for
Simplicity so this will give a total
running time uh of ND Times
login okay uh and that's the first term
that we get here and the second term
from comes from all the updates and this
is how we get this for them um are there
any questions so this is all I have for
the obious updates
part yes so when you update
a so when you update a you need to
update this sketch metrix yes when you
update sketch Matrix to is that like
easy to see yeah so like it's the
hardest part is still to update the
inverse here you can just use the VAR
boil down to like mrix back
um I I like I think I'm just like not
getting it
but like do you update the Matrix that
you use to compute these upper bands on
The Leverage scores or like is it a zero
all the time or you do update you do
update it and because yeah this is
something I'm hiding under the rock uh
because this Matrix is some substance
embedding of your actual Matrix this
will give some um approximation to the L
score so you just lose some constant in
the Su
here
okay
[Music]
okay okay so next let me move on to our
upper Bound for incremental but
adap sorry can I ask question about the
so when you are making this update how
do you manage like the interaction
between the randomness
of maybe there is nothing to manage like
like you you're doing something that
depends
on yes yeah yeah exactly uh so that's
what I'm G to put right here
um yeah maybe let me go over this slide
first and then see if that answers your
question already um so next let me move
on to the Adaptive updates so first of
all if we're only considering oblivious
updates then that would not be a problem
because your updates are all just
fixed um and if we're considering
adaptive updates it would be a problem
when our algorithm uses Randomness in it
and our algorithm does use Randomness in
it and where does our algorithm use
Randomness well there are two parts that
we use Randomness the first part is when
we are using this JL trick to estimate
all the leverage scores and how to make
that word against adaptive upas is
actually pretty easy what we do is that
we just make the JL estimate and
overestimate so we just increase it
manually by some constant
Factor uh so that makes sure that we
always sample with a higher probability
than what the exact algorithm would do
and whenever we actually perform an
update we will renew use a JL sketch
immediately and never reuse it so in
this way our JL sketch is um never
reused we never really leak any
information to the adversary so this
part is actually easy and the hard part
is how to make the sampling itself work
against adaptive updates because when
you're are sampling um you sample your
sample
probability
uh like the aders adversary can see
whether you sample the row or not not in
the previous iteration and that could
change their decision of what is the new
role that you wanted to put and that can
make it hard does
that I think I was wondering if there's
already something that needs to be
managed in the oblivious
setting because of how your
like your probabilities which determine
what updates you make depend on the JL
sketch but then you sketch a new thing
based on these
updates oh so I think it's fine because
the JL sketch can work for unfixed
vectors and you can think of all the
vectors that you have for all the
iterations are all fixed yeah okay
okay but it will be a problem but since
we res sketch renew this ja anyways so
it's fine like this part doesn't really
lose anything yeah so do you have to
renew the sketch when a row is included
or whenever you toss a coin whenever a
row is included when you just toss a
coin you don't yeah so is that obvious
when you toss like if I tossed a coin
but it failed doesn't that change the
conditioning why is it obvious that you
don't need to refresh the JL sketch at
that point the reason is because the JL
sketch is an overestimate so even you
can consider uh we do this algorithm
with another ideal algorithm that use a
new J sketch in every single iteration
and whenever this ideal algorithm
doesn't sample any role our true
algorithm also doesn't sample any role
and once you don't sample any role you
just leak this binary information to the
adversary of this is just a zero
decision or a one decision and when you
are not sampling any row our algorithm
will perform exactly the same as this
ideal algorithm that renew s sketch in
every single iteration so we are not
really leaking any information so that
is fine but once we sample a rle we
could leaking some information just by
this binary decision because there could
be situations we sampling a row but the
ideal algorithm is not something of R
because we are an
overestimate but when that happens we
just immediately renew the JL sketch so
that is also fine because we just don't
it
yes sorry sorry to ask another question
uh um yeah in the is it clear like which
step of the so I I thought in the online
leverage score sampling framework you're
only using like two facts one is like
that they're always overestimates and
one is that the sum is always bounded
right the the second fact is like
clearly just always true right uh the
first one I guess like is where you
would be worried for adaptive updates
but I would have imagined like in each
step you're still independently sampling
like is there like a obvious counter
example why that why it why it's harder
the reason why it doesn't work is not
like any of those parts this doesn't
work it's because uh when you're are
trying to prove leverage sampling gives
some Subspace embedding some spectral
approximation of the Matrix that proof
itself doesn't carry over for adaptive
updates that's actually what I'm going
to talk about under next slide so I hope
it will be make it clearer once I go
over this okay so on this slide I'm
exactly going to answer that question
why isn't it obvious that leverage score
samping would it's hard to make it work
for adaptive updates why let's go back
to so to answer this we need to go back
to the proof of why lever sore sampling
will give you some Subspace embedding so
let's recall this is the L samply we say
that we stample it and we'll get some
sub Subspace embedding and what is the
normal standard proof for this um for
this LMA the standard proof uses the
Matrix chof bound which is basically
says that if I have a bunch of
independently random PSD matrices X1 to
xn if they all have some upper bound
then we can know that the least IG value
of the sum of all these independent
matrices the probability that this is at
most one minus absolon of the
expectation of these random matrices
this is founded by like some
exponentially small probability and we
can also get a similar Bound for the
largest agon value and now when we're
proving The Leverage score sampling Lama
we will Define the independent random
matrices as the rank one Matrix of our R
so depending on whether you s our Ro or
not yeah there people talking during
your to it's making it really difficult
you oh are there any questions I'll have
a question a minute but go ahead yeah
okay so we Define our random variable
Matrix uh as a rank one Matrix and then
we apply the Matrix term of round to it
but we can't just apply it directly
because we just apply directly the only
give up some bound on the least IG value
or the largest igon value but we can use
a very simple trick by uh scale our
random variable by the expectation so
now um after we do the scaling the
expectation of the scaled version would
just be identity so if you have some
bound on the least ion value and some
bound on the largest IG value this will
give us a band on all the IG values
because this is just identity and this
proves the spectr of approximation of
the Matrix and that gives us the
approximation priority that we needed
okay so what about we just use this for
the Adaptive updates well for the
Adaptive updates we also have some
similar adaptive Matrix turnoff bound
but here the key problem here is that in
this LMA the the weight Matrix sorry the
expectation Matrix W is not a fixed
Matrix anymore by definition this Matrix
itself is a random variable so it's the
summation of all the x i conditioned on
the previous um matrices so this x so if
you just look at one term so this
expectation this expectation itself is a
random variable that depends on what
you're conditioned on so it depends on
this X1 to x i minus one and now in the
LMA because this W is a random variable
itself in the LMA we can only show that
for any fixed value mu the probability
that the least singular value of the
summation is less than one minus Epson
time mu and the probability of this
random variable that is the expectation
is larger than mu is smaller than some
exponential probability that depends on
me okay so it's the key thing is that W
is a random variable here and because W
is a random variable we cannot Define
the scale diversion anymore it's not
even well defined why because W itself
depends on whether we sample the I row
or not so it depends on XI so this thing
is not um not even well defined
anymore so we cannot do what we did
previously in our previous slide for the
oblivious case but what we can do is
that we can guess what is the value of
this uh expectation Matrix W so
basically we can for we can comp use
this found for uh 2 to the D Squared
number of fixed values and then still
prove a similar concentration bound as
before but because we will need to guess
over all these uh possible values of the
Matrix and we wanted to sum them up by
using a union bound so we need a much
smaller success probability and that's
why we will need to increase our
sampling probability because sampling
probability actually have a log one over
Delta term in it so we need to increase
it by d s time L this is one way that we
can prove it but that's not what we
showed in the paper because um we have
some way better that only lose D times
Lo compared to e s okay are there any
questions for these two
slides yeah um do you know whether just
like the exact same algorithm as online
row sampling fails we don't know that's
a great question we don't I think this
is a very interesting open problem we
saw it for a little bit but don't have
anything whether there exist any lower
band that separates the oblivious case
and the DAT case right now it only fails
in the analysis it's us exactly the same
algorithm we just need to increase the
constant before the sampling
probability any other
questions okay so next let me go to uh
what we actually do in the paper and how
we actually get
this okay so this is the LMA that we
proved in our paper we show that we have
the row from A1 to a n that's is
adaptive sequence and then we sample the
ice r with some probability proportional
to the online leverage scores but with
some factor C here and then we Pro that
D is a subac value of a so our paper is
based on this previous result by B at
all but they have a linear dependence on
cap so let me first talk about their
proof ideas so what they show is that
instead of proving the spectral
approximation of the matrices they
reduce it to the scalar case to just
prove uh the al2 norm approximation for
some fixed vectors V and they need to
prove this for all of these in some
absolon net and the size of the Epsilon
net is roughly C or Epsilon to
of and then by using a union bound over
all the vs in the absolon net um we will
need to have an actual dependence of log
one/ Delta and log of this thing is
roughly D Times log I'm hiding some like
log one or absolon here okay and this is
also the reason why we lose a d Times
log factor that exactly comes from using
this Union Bound for the scalar case
okay but there algorithm not only loses
this Factor they also lose another Capa
factor and the reason that they lose the
other Capa factor is because now we can
Define our scalar random variables for a
fixed vector v and ideally we would like
to prove the sum of all these error
terms in every every row is bounded by
the sum of your final exact Norm so
they're bounded by some Epsilon times
your final Matrix times
V and then they use some uh scalar
version of the concentration Bound for
adaptive updates and this scalar version
also only hold for some fixed value me
so you can show that the probability
that this thing is larger than some
fixed value me is bounded by like
exponential function of mu so ideally
what we would like to do is we would
like to set mu equals to the SP that we
want and we directly give us what we
want but this is similar to The Matrix
turn of fan case this Norm itself is a
random variable because it depends on
what are your future roles and what your
future roles could depend on whether you
sampled your previous Ro or not because
the roles are given by some
adversary so what they showed in their
paper they just use a naive band to band
this upper band um by the singular
values and that's why they lose a Kapa
Factor
and what we show that is similar to what
I described for the Matrix case we also
guess what is this random variable so by
Guess more concretely we means we build
an Epsilon net over a line segment um
that's all the possible that's includes
this Norm so it's the range of this norm
and then for any fixed value s in this
Epsilon net we can define a truncated
sequence so we can define a truncated
sequence which call XS such that it
equals to our the variable that we care
about x i as long as up to the ice
iteration our gas s is still a good
upper bound of this norm and then for
any of those trunc sequence we can prove
concentration now because we can just
set mu to be Epsilon times s squ now s
is our gas so it's a fixed thing and we
can prove this for all s in the absolute
net but then we again need to sum all
the failure probabilities of all these
gases by using the union bound and now
we only lose a log Capa Factor because
the size of the absolon net is roughly
Kapa and then we just lose a log factor
of that okay and then that gives our
upper Bound for the Adaptive case so the
first term is still the same as
previously but in the second term
because we lose a Deca Factor so we will
lose like to times Factor here okay any
questions for this upper bound section
how is the depend here uh it's still
polinomial Oh you mean like exactly it's
Epsilon yeah so it looks like you have
poly one over Epsilon is it Epsilon the
five as well here no I think it's abson
to the minus 4 because the number of
rows that you sample is like Square you
would lose right I mean so where is the
extra Epson Square coming
from for the EPS that you POS on no I
think from the abso net we just get a
log one abso so don't really lose
anything okay so where do you lose the
extra so are you going to argue that
this is tight or the D to the five over
the poly no I'm not sure if it is tight
or not that's yeah that's just when we
get right now but this is like doesn't
really matter if n is much larger than
well I mean lot of questions whether
it's larger or yes
yes in real data would be very
yeah I do think this is a very
interesting question whether we can get
a same upper Bound for the Adaptive case
or case yeah okay um so there are no
more questions next I will move to the
lower bound part uh let me first um
State our lower bound lemas again so as
we show in the upper bound our
dependence on Epsilon is polinomial and
our first lower run basically says there
is indeed a separation between the high
accuracy regime and the low accuracy
regime so we can't possibly get um more
than d square better than D Squared
amortized update time if we wanted to
maintain a very very good approximate
solution and the second separation is
between the fully Dynamic case and the
incremental case okay and all of our
lower bounds are based on this om
conjecture which is a pretty widely used
conjecture in Fu complexity so um so
this in this conjecture we consider the
online Matrix Vector multiplication
problem so initially we are given some
Matrix some Boolean Matrix M of size d
byd and then in each deration we're
given a booing Vector VI and the
algorithm needs to Output The Matrix
Vector product M times this vector v in
the ice run and the conjecture states
that there is no algorithm for this omv
problem that can we can allow it to have
polinomial preprocessing time uh there's
no algorithm that have better than D
Squared amortised query time in each
generation okay uh and you think about
it if we can have all these update
vectors in the beginning if you give
them as a batch then we can use fast
Matrix modifcation to get something
that's faster so basically this
conjecture says if you're if you don't
do that if you give them one by one then
uh all this multiplication will take D
cubed time
so high Lely it this conure to say that
the only way to speed up Matrix Vector
multiplication is by batching these
vectors together and there's nothing
better we can do they're all online and
this is a unified uh conjecture that can
be used to prove many conditional lower
bounds for dynamic Pro problems a lot of
them are shown in the original paper
that this
conjecture okay uh and it also holds if
we have a number of queries instead of
just the queries and that's the version
that I will use in our lower bounds okay
so next let me show you a road map of
how we prove our lower bounds so we
start from the omv conjecture that says
this omv problem will need d square time
and we first reduce it to a SE om
problem but for real valued matrices
that allows a one polinomial
approximation error uh and we also
reduce it to a projection version
whereas The Matrix some projection
Matrix but this is not very important
this is more for technical reasons so we
first reduce this and we say that in
order to just get a one over polyd
approximate solution for this real value
om problem it will take D squ CH and
then from that we can directly reduce to
the one over polyon approximate
incremental Le s regression because here
uh the the approximation error is very
small but in order to get this constant
approximation l lower Bound for the
fully dynamically Square regression we
need to start from some hardness result
that also have a constant error
somewhere even though the first term is
a relative error while the second term
is a additive error so the main
technical the key Lema of all our lower
band proofs is actually this proof here
to have some hardness application that
shows that even if you wanted to have a
looser approximation that's a constant
relative error it still will need D
Squared time so this this is the key LMA
okay so next let me see I have 10 more
minutes I will quickly go through these
two steps just cover some high level
ideas but not go into the details and
then I will go into more details of how
we prove this key Lemma because I wanted
to give you uh the statement of this
Lemma and I hope that it will be also be
useful for some other future research
for other conditional low okay but let
me start from
here okay so um now we wanted to reduce
so let me first give you the statement
of this one over polyd approximate omv
problem so here we assume that our
Matrix have a real values instead of
just bulling values but we need to
somehow sorry we need to assume that it
has constant igen values so we need to
assume that all the Norms are constants
and we also assume that the query
vectors all have unit norms and then we
want the algorithm to Output some vector
by I that have a one over D additive
error comparing to the exact
solution okay and this problem will take
D Squared um time if the OM conjecture
is true okay so now when we are trying
to prove this step here we will assume
that we have a very very good uh Oracle
for the incrementally square regression
problem we assume it has a one over n
time some polinomial of the approximate
solution and we wanted to use this ER
Oracle to compute use some Vector Yi for
this omv problem that's how the proof
goes so we construct the Le Square
regressions instance such that our
initial inverse Matrix equals to The
Matrix M that we want in the OMB
problem and then we add some row AI
That's uh the query Vector but scale it
down by n times some Pol of D and
because we scale it down so this this
Vector will have a very very small norm
and it's very important that with scale
it down by something that's in that's
why we only get like this hardness
result for one hour po approximation
because of that then all these rows
doesn't really change our Matrix at all
so even if we add all these rows the
inverse is still uh up to very small
Arrow roughly the same as our initial
Matrix and then by the Woodberry
identity the difference between the two
LSR Solutions will exactly give us the
Matrix Vector product of M times this AI
so now we can just scale up the
difference between these two SSR
Solutions and use that to recover some
approximate solution uh for our om
problem okay any questions for this
slide yes so so at the end you round
these vectors because you know the
vectors you received were binary Yeah so
basically you you are trying to design
an algorithm for this problem and then
you just call the Oracle in each
Direction
and from the Oracle you will receive
some solution for the Le s but you get
approximate answers right and then you
but you need to round them
to uh right there are some run right
you're using the integrality of the omv
conjecture there are some running yes in
this part yeah yeah thank you
yeah okay uh and then next let me go to
the Second Step where we reduce from
this um stronger um hardness result to
the constant approximate fully dynamic
I will only be able to cover some very
high level Tech ideas here because this
is a little more
technical so similar as before um so we
have we wanted to solve some online
projection problem where our Matrix is a
projection Matrix and then we have we
wanted to Output some Vector that have
some um constant relative error and then
one we po additive error and now we
assume that we have a constant
approximation but fully Dynamic the
square regression orle
and this fully Dynamic descri Oracle is
more powerful in the incremental Oracle
in the sense that in our reduction we
can still add a roow that's some scaled
version of the query Vector in the ice
rang but after the ice run we
immediately delete this row and then in
the next R we get a new row and then we
delete it once we recover the solution
so that's what we how we use this that's
why this is important that it's fully
Dynamic and I'm hiding a lot of details
but similar as before
um the difference between our solution
in the ice run and the initial solution
will roughly give us M times or the
vector that we care about but with some
constant error and because we get some
constant error here it's very important
that we need to reduce from some harness
result that itself has allowed some
constant error okay so that's why we
need this stronger uh online projection
hardness result and that will see so
that will be what will talk about um
now so now I'm ready to Define uh this
online projection problem more
rigorously so in the online projection
problem initially we're given some
projection Matrix that will project a
vector to the Subspace of uh denoted by
U and then we are given a sequence of
unit vectors as the query vectors and
then we I will use this notation V with
subscript U to denote the project the
compon component of the vector VI
projected to the Subspace U and the
algorithm needs to Output there are two
different types of approximations the
stronger types we only allow when poly
additive error where some Yi uh the
difference between Yi and the exact
solution is bounded by one over
polyd and a looser approximation is
where we still have a one polyd additive
error but we also allow a constant
relative error so it's some constant
times the norm of the exact
solution okay and the harness
application keyma LMA says that if we
have the harness result that there is no
D Squared time algorithm for this one
over polyd additive era online
projection problem then we also know
that there is no d square time algorithm
for this one over three relative error
online projection problem okay so how
our proof is going to go is we will
wanted to solve this online projection
problem um to this higher accuracy but
we assume that we have some low accuracy
oracles so we assume that we have two
oracles one that projects the vector
into the Subspace of U and another one
that projects the vector into the
Subspace of the oogo component of U
which I will denote by this U oogo and
we will use
poly log number of Oracle calls to these
two Oracles in order to recover a vector
that has a higher
accuracy okay so how do we do um the
first attempt is as follows so we're
given some vector v and then we can
decompose it into two orthogonal
components one in the Subspace of U and
one in the sub of U uh alog space of you
and then we have this more Lucy
um Oracle so the first idea is in each
interation we just use this lossy Oracle
to compute the component some but with
some error so we just project V into
this orthogonal space to compute some
Vector W but this W will have some
error and then we remove uh this
component so we compute V minus W so
this V minus W will be closer to V and
then we can continue this for log D
times and then so that the component in
this orthogonal space is smaller and
smaller it starts from some constant but
after Lotty times will be one over
polyd okay so like we do this again
again and again but there's a small
problem with this first attempt the
problem is that when we are doing when
we're using this Oracle to compute some
W that approximates the component in the
AAL space it will introduce error in
both directions will introduce error
both in this aogo space and also in the
space unit that we care about so in the
end we will get some Vector that is
almost completely inside U but this
Vector will have some error that's more
than polinomial so we'll have some
pretty large error and we need to remove
that error so what do we do is that we
use what we showed on this slide as a
black box and do another level of
reduction on top of it so what we've
shown is that we know how to compute
some Vector y That's approximately to v
u and it has nearly zero component in
this orthogonal space but on the other
hand we can also reverse it we can also
compute some Vector W that is almost
completely in the orthogonal space and
there it has no component in the space u
so instead of computing just instead of
just using one Oracle call to the
projection Oracle and compute this lossy
Vector w we instead use what we showed
on the previous slide and use this log D
number of iteration to compute this W
star that is almost completely in this
Subspace we um aogo Subspace and now
what we do what we did before we again
remove this this uh vector and because
now we make sure that our error all stay
in the orthogonal space so it's fine so
we don't introduce any extra error in
the space that we care about and now we
again repeat it for log D times and then
we reduce the constant relative error to
one or poly the additive error okay so
that's all I wanted to say and I also
wanted to mention that somehow this is a
little similar to the iterative
refinement algorithms that di talked
about in the previous slide so I think
there is
some intuition that could be the same
between the lower bands and the upper
bands okay um as a summary what we
talking about today is Absol approximate
dynamically Square regression problem
and we showed a OD proper B when we only
want constant approximation and then we
only have incremental updates and we
show lower bance that says that we can't
really improve these two conditions
these two are both necessary and let me
list some open problems uh the first one
is right now on the for adaptive
incremental updates and for oblivious
incremental updates there's still a gap
in the second term and this only shows
up in the analysis the algorithm is
still the same so we want to know if we
can improve this term and the second
problem is uh all this only works for
the most simple al2 regression problem
and then we there's no I don't know any
algorithm that work for the harder LP
regression uh and then for the lower
band the lower band right now only works
for fully Dynamic and adaptive setting
we don't know anything about fully
Dynamic and oblivious
setting and finally um I think this um
constant relative eror online projection
Oracle LMA could be interesting on
itself and then I wonder if there are
other reductions that can come from this
harder Conant approximate hard yeah
that's all thank
[Applause]
you thanks a lot for the talk uh can can
you tell us briefly how in the
how so the lower bar for fully fully
Dynamic Works only for adaptive updates
but you can can you say when you did
when did you need this
yes so it's here so when we are we call
the Oracle here and then remove this and
then use this new Vector as a a query
Vector for the Oracle again so it's very
very adaptive all this Pro I see
thanks
uh is there a reason you didn't look at
decremental
settings we just didn't look at because
our ination started from this continue
ml where you're always collecting new
data so but I think that's an
interesting open problem as well you can
have something for the decal
model
you uh gave a quick comment
onization and is there hope for
deterministic
algorith yeah that's also a great
question because if you have some
deterministic algorithm then there's no
issue of adaptive updates anymore
because it works for both of them but I
don't really know because now the upper
bound heavily depends on the sampling
algorithm we know that if you are static
then there's some way to compute you
don't really need to do sampling you can
use the algorithm to keep some row but I
don't know how to make that dynamize it
seems very expensive do do we even know
static algorithm that is deterministic
and has running time and
D no I think you can sample the same
number of rows but the running time is
much larger so it means like the the
barrier for deterministic dynamic
algorithm is even in the static setting
I think so in terms of running times
yeah
I think you said this but I lost it so
is this approximate projection thing
this conjecture is implied by the normal
omv conjecture or it's like a different
conjecture oh this is implied by the OM
and then like all the reductions related
to this like where were you a why were
you be able why are you able to assume
that you had access to both you and you
per uh uh that's a good question because
in the OM conjecture it would also hold
if you allow polom pre-processing time
so we in the preprocessing time you can
just compute the AAL Matrix as well by
using like e toega time oh I see so it's
like you're you're taking your you have
some initial Matrix and you yeah you
have the initial projection Matrix and
then you have many many queries think
about this like a large polom of D but
you allow yourself some polinomial time
it's still hard in the conjecture okay
cool awesome
thanks well I guess if you have no more
questions then we thank speaker
again